Body and stunt doubles are the unsung heroes
of the movie industry, putting themselves
on the line so actors getting paid a lot more
money get to look awesome.
Thanks to the magic of editing, stunt doubles
don't have to look all that much like the
actor they're filling in for, but sometimes
a production needs someone with a strong physical
resemblance to a star.
Who better to call on than an actor's close
relative?
These films took advantage of shared DNA to
pull off some tricky scenes, leaving audiences
none the wiser.
Pirates of the Caribbean: On Stranger Tides
In the fourth installment of the Pirates of
the Caribbean franchise, series leading lady
Keira Knightley was replaced by Penélope
Cruz, who got some great news soon after the
filming of On Stranger Tides began ...
"I am with child.
Yours!"
The father is actually fellow Spanish actor
Javier Bardem, the villain of the film's follow-up,
Dead Men Tell No Tales.
The news put a kink in the production's plans,
considering her character is introduced in
a tricky three-minute swordfighting scene
her doctor would likely deem too risky.
Sure, she's dressed up like Jack Sparrow …
"Hello Angelica."
"Hello Jack."
… so they could have used any ol' stunt
double, but Cruz's younger sister Monica proved
to be a far better match, as a trained dancer
with swordfighting experience.
Monica reportedly doubled for Penélope during
most of her fight scenes, as well as a number
of full body shots later in production to
hide her sister's burgeoning baby bump.
Forrest Gump
Tom Hanks didn't actually pound the pavement
the entire time they were filming those cross-country
running scenes in Forrest Gump.
His younger brother Jim filled in for him
for a few hundred yards shot in Montana and
South Carolina.
Along with bearing a strong physical resemblance
to his brother, Jim's voice is virtually identical
to that of his famous sibling …
"There's no crying in voicemail!"
… which has earned him gigs voicing Sheriff
Woody in Toy Story video games, straight-to-DVD
movies, and more …
"Ha ha!
Boy am I glad to see you."
"Is that you?"
"No, it's my brother, Jim."
(Laughter)
"Is that really?"
"Yeah."
Furious 7
After Paul Walker's untimely death in 2013
midway through filming Furious 7, the future
of the entire Fast and the Furious franchise
was called into question.
Production was temporarily halted while the
studio sorted out options—one of which was
using CGI to put his face onto one of his
two brothers, Caleb and Cody, and have them
film the rest of his scenes.
With the exception of a few CGI shots deconstructed
to show the process used to revive him for
the role, the studio hasn't revealed which
scenes are real and which are fake, but about
350 overall shots had to be altered.
The end result is a film where it's near impossible
to tell exactly when you're looking at Paul
Walker, re-purposed footage spliced into the
scene, his face CGI'd onto one of his brother's
bodies, or even a combination of all three.
Most of The Rock's movies
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson is a physically
massive human being, so there aren't too many
stuntmen who could convincingly pretend to
be him, right?
Well, there is one: Tanoai Reed, who also
happens to be his cousin … and also happens
to be the size of a refrigerator.
"This has nothing to do with saving people.
These are refrigerators."
"This is Baywatch, p----!"
As one of the few human beings with arms equal
in size to his cousin, Reed has been working
as his stunt double for virtually his entire
acting career.
In fact, Reed has doubled for his cousin for
so long, he appeared in the films that still
credited Dwayne as "The Rock", the ones in
which he starred as Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson,
and, of course, the more recent blockbusters
crediting him simply as Dwayne Johnson, including
the Baywatch reboot …
"If you want me, you can have me."
"Some other time."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!